Harry Kersh: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Shake Shack in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, burgers come in two sizes,
single and double.
Joe Avella: And in the US,
our Shake Shack burgers
also come in single or double.
Harry: We're gonna weigh
the Double ShackBurger
to find out if it's actually
the same size in the UK
as it is in the US.
Joe: Oh, man.
Ours weighs a lot less.
Significantly less.
What's up with that, Shake Shack?
Harry: In the UK, we can
only get fries in one size,
and this is it.
Joe: In the US, we also
have only one size of fries.
Let's see how much thleh bleh!
What I meant to say was,
let's see how much they weigh!
Harry: So, our portion of
fries came to around 188 grams.
Joe: What?
Did he say 188?
Ours is, like, a little over 100.
Like, when I say 105, I might be generous.
It's a lot less.
So far, the fries and the burger
have been significantly
smaller than the UK.
I thought we were the ones
with the big portions.
Harry: Drinks from a UK Shake Shack
come in two sizes, regular and large.
Joe: The US, we also have
only two fountain-drink sizes,
regular and large.
Harry: We're gonna
measure them to find out
how much is actually in these.
So, a regular drink from a UK Shake Shack
has about 400 milliliters in it.
Joe: Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, woop.
Oh, I should've done the big one first.
Little over 16 ounces.
[laughs]
It fits. That's good.
It has gone slightly over the scales.
I'm gonna, in my infinite wisdom,
assume that's around 600 milliliters.
Give or take a few.
Joe: So that's 16.
Jump to the little guy.
Huh.
6 1/2.
16 plus 6 is 24?
Right?
22?
Heh.
We'll give it a half,
so 22 1/2 fluid ounces for the large.
Harry: Milkshakes in the
UK only come in one size.
We're not sure what it is,
so, again, we're gonna measure it.
Joe: In the US, our shakes
also come in one size.
I mean, this thing might
be to-the-line 16 ounces.
Uh-oh, got some bad news, Conner.
Looks like it's a little under 16 ounces.
Mm.
Harry: Importantly, in the UK you can also
get beer from Shake Shack.
This normally comes in
a serving of one pint.
However, unfortunately,
due to the reduced menu
from the pandemic, we
couldn't get one today.
Joe: The Shake Shacks in the US
are still serving beer.
So, the ones we got to go were cans.
Got the 12 ounce and the 16 ounce.
I'm gonna assume, since
it's the same size cup,
that this is a pint.
Harry: Fun pint fact for you.
Our pints in the UK are actually bigger
than your pints in the US.
We use imperial measurements,
and our pints are around 19 ounces,
whereas yours are 16.
Joe: If all pints were
magically half the size,
I'm just drinking twice as much.
I've never stopped to think
how many fluid ounces is in a beer.
It's like, get me outta here!
Harry: What about hot dogs?
Well, a hot dog from a UK Shake Shack
is 6 1/2 inches long.
[Joe sighs]
What in the heck is this?
They cut the hot dog in half?
Cursed image.
Am I getting punk'd here?
First Five Guys, and now Shake Shack?
I get it, I'm fighting a losing battle.
Against normal hot dogs.
Yeah, I mean, Five Guys reached out to me.
Haven't heard back from them, though,
at the recording of this.
Shake Shack, you're on the list now too.
You're on the list now too.
I wanna know what's going
on with these hot dogs.
I did not bring the tape measurer,
but the good people at Apple have an app
that measures stuff for us.
This shoot, of course,
is sponsored by Apple.
All right.
So, I'm going to measure this hot dog.
This is actually working!
6 1/2 inches.
Thank you, Apple.
Harry: And it weighs 126 grams.
Joe: It looks like it's,
like, exactly on 125.
Harry: And last but by no means least,
Shake Shack in the UK and the US
are both known for being
quite dog-friendly.
And as such, you can
get dog treats.
These are red velvet dog treats,
and they come in packs of five.
Joe: They were saying
theirs are red velvet.
I don't know what ours are supposed to be.
Oh, it's got the Shake Shack logo on it.
You see that?
Ooh, I don't like how they smell.
[crunching]
Oddly a little bit like a Communion wafer.
I'm not getting red velvet.
Now we're gonna get the
expert opinion on dog treats.
Doggo: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
this is "Doggo Wars."
Hey, Mabel.
Megan Ingham: Yeah, there's chips on the floor.
Harry: Wait.
This is Mabel the dog,
and she's gonna taste-test
the treats for us.
Go on, Mabel.
Mabel: Yum.
Megan: Mabel, stay!
[laughing]
Harry: This is Mabel the dog,
and we're gonna get her thoughts
on the dog treats from Shake Shack.
What'd you think, Mabel?
Mabel: Wow.
Harry: Not bad?
Mabel: Not bad.
Harry: Do you taste red velvet?
Mabel: No.
Harry: I don't know if
she tastes the red velvet,
but she seems to be enjoying it,
so, good job, guys.
Joe: Bring me the dogs.
[Joe whistling]
Hey, Paul!
What do you think?
Both dogs: Treat!
Joe: You want a big one?
How is it, how is it, how is it?
Luda: Needs salt.
Joe: I mean, you see that,
you see what I was talking about before
about, like, they're like,
almost like those matzo crackers you get,
those really, like, tasteless
ones that your mom gets
because she doesn't want you
eating all that salt or whatever?
I don't know if these would be my
top favorite go-to dog treats,
but in a pinch, yeah.
So, what've you been up
to during quarantine?
Harry: Unfortunately, Shake
Shack in the UK doesn't disclose
any of its nutritional information.
Joe: However, we can get
nutritional information in the US.
So let's start with the
calories in a standard meal.
If you get the Double
ShackBurger and the fries
and a chocolate shake, you're
looking at 2,010 calories,
which is just a little bit over
your entire daily recommended allowance.
So just eat this every day once.
What if you're in the mood for
something even unhealthier?
Well, this right here is the
Double SmokeShack burger,
and it's the most calorific
standard burger at Shake Shack.
Clocks in at 870 calories.
Just the burger.
Harry: This is also the menu item
with the highest fat content.
In the US, one of these
contains 57 grams of fat,
which is 73% of your daily allowance.
Joe: It's also the
saltiest thing on the menu.
A Double SmokeShack contains a huge
3,030 milligrams of sodium.
That's over 130% of your daily allowance.
Harry: Shake Shack is also
unique in its approach
to regional specialties, with
pretty much every location
having an exclusive burger or custard.
However, some of these are
way less healthy than others.
Joe: For example, the least healthy burger
found on any Shake Shack menu
is a Lockhart Link burger.
This is exclusive only to Austin, Texas,
so listen up, all you
relocating tech bros and Joe Rogan.
This is a burger with
jalapeño cheese, ShakeSauce,
pickles, and a sausage
link from Kreuz Market
in, you guessed it, Lockhart.
Harry: If you get one
of these as a triple,
it contains over half
of your daily calories,
more than 100% of your daily fat,
and almost double your daily sodium.
Joe: But the most calorific item
found on any Shake Shack menu
actually isn't a burger.
It's something called
the Double Down fries.
They're found only in Vegas.
Double Down? Got it? OK.
And they contain 1,910 calories.
Those fries alone are 95%
of your daily allowance.
I mean, give me a break. You're in Vegas.
Like you care at all, right?
Give me the fries, I just lost my fortune.
Harry: Unfortunately,
Shake Shack in the UK
also doesn't disclose its ingredients.
Bit shady. What's going on there, guys?
Give us some info to work with.
Joe: And that's also
the case here in the US.
We've reached out to them to see
if they'd make an exception,
but they could not help us out.
Harry: What we can get
is a list of allergens,
and it has a couple of fun things to note.
For example, there is a
significant risk of there being
traces of seafood in
our banoffee concrete,
and they're also sulfites
in our chicken bites
and in the ShackSauce.
Joe: We may or may not also have shellfish
in our 'Shroom burger, ShackBurger,
Shack Stack, and SmokeShack.
So, there's no potential
seafood in the UK equivalents
of these burgers, so I have no idea
why there might be shellfish
in ours here in the US.
I couldn't even guess why.
But in better news, all our Shake Shacks,
US beef, it's freshly
ground 100% Angus beef
that's free from hormones and antibiotics.
And the buns are non-GMO.
Harry: Here is everything
you can only find
on the menu at a UK Shake Shack.
Joe: Here are all the
US-exclusive Shake Shack items
you cannot get in the UK.
Harry: Let's start with the burgers.
Here we have the
ShackMeister burger.
Now, this is a double version.
It comes with beef patties,
cheese, ShackSauce,
and then some crispy
ale-marinated shallots.
Yes, we pronounce it "shall-OTS."
That's the correct way to pronounce it.
You guys are wrong.
For a limited time in the UK
we can also get a spicy version
of the chicken sandwich,
which is the hot chicken sandwich.
This comes in hot,
or extra hot if you're feeling bold.
We would usually be able to get some
more exclusive hot-dog options,
including a Shack-cago dog,
which I think you might be able to get
as, like, a secret menu item in the US,
and also a ShackMeister sausage,
which is kind of like a hot dog,
but with a Cumberland-style sausage,
which is something that's kind
of popular here in the UK.
But, unfortunately, due to
the reduced pandemic menu,
we weren't able to get these.
Joe: Harry, you know my
feelings about the hot dogs,
you know my feelings
about hot dogs in general,
and I will say, as someone who was
born and raised in "Shack-cago,"
I would love to try the Shack-cago hot dog
at the UK Shake Shack.
So, when I come to visit,
that'll be our first stop.
Harry: Now, on top of
the limited-edition
hot chicken burger,
we can also currently get
some hot chicken bites,
as well as some spicy fries.
Joe: So, the only two sandwiches
that we were able to get our hands on
that are exclusive to the US
and not in the UK are the grilled cheese
and the Korean chicken sandwich.
OK, first things first,
this grilled cheese.
Look at this thing!
Did you, is it, do you sit on this, too?
This is ridiculous!
I wouldn't pay a dollar for this.
It looks like they took two buns,
put cheese in it, and then, I don't know,
ran over it with a
steamroller or something.
Why is this so thin?
What does look actually
♪ bomb ♪
is this, the Korean chicken sandwich.
Yo. Yes!
Yes to this.
Oh, my goodness.
With the kimchi.
I'm telling you, I'm telling you.
You want that.
Also a thing the Shake Shack in the US has
that you can't get in the UK
are the breakfast sandwiches.
We're shooting this, like, at 4 p.m.,
so surprise to no one,
the breakfast sandwiches
were not available.
But, usually, if you get there
I'm assuming before 10:30 or 11,
you can get a bacon, egg, and cheese;
sausage, egg, and cheese;
and just an egg and cheese.
Check 'em out.
I have no idea if they taste good or not.
Also a thing you can get in the US
is cheesy bacon fries.
But this has been sitting
for more than a minute.
Oh, my God, I think it's
gonna come out like a disk!
[laughs] Oh, God!
I wanna make this perfectly clear:
This is not an indictment
of Shake Shack quality.
This has been sitting for,
what, at least two hours?
I mean, it's bacon and cheese on fries.
Even at that consistency,
it's still pretty good.
I mentioned this before,
but there's, like,
all these different regional
things throughout the country,
so I don't know if this
whole Korean sandwich
and Korean chicken bites
is just in this area.
But I think I'm about to lose my mind.
Yo, you want this.
Oh, yes!
Yes to these.
Yes to these!
Harry: Now, much like
the way US Shake Shacks
have exclusive burgers and custards,
some of the UK branches also have
exclusive options themselves.
The one we went to had a dessert option
called the Union Shack, which
is a really terrible pun
on the Union Jack, which is our flag.
Now, it's effectively
just a chocolate custard
with some chocolate from
British chocolatiers.
However, unfortunately,
due to the pandemic,
reduced menu, couldn't get that either.
And, of course, it wouldn't
be a Shake Shack episode
unless we talked about the shakes.
Now, the UK-wide exclusive flavors
include coffee and caramel,
and then the branch we visited
also had a cinnamon toast shake,
which I'm really intrigued by.
Mixy, mixy.
It's not bad.
Very sweet, and quite cinnamony,
as you would expect.
Joe: It's so many different
menu items across regions
it'd be impossible for us
to cover all the things
at every specific Shake
Shack in the US alone,
so given the ones that
we had that we went to,
the three exclusive shakes we have are
brownie batter hot cocoa,
vanilla black sugar, cookies and cream.
Once again, end of the
day, end of the shoot.
Gonna put me into a coma after this.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Like, it has a little bit of, like,
an extra chocolatyness to it.
It's not too sweet.
The caramel flavor is there,
but it isn't, like, chemically tasting.
That's the one to beat.
Cookies and cream, baby.
♪ Cookies and cream ♪
Woop.
There we go.
I can't decide if that one's better.
That's so good.